Resuelve para "x" y tenemos "x" menos 8 es
igual a "x" sobre 3 más 1/6.
Y lo que voy a hacer aquí aunque hay varias
maneras de hacer esto, lo que yo voy a hacer
aquí es simplificar las fracciones, para
esto voy a multiplicar toda la ecuación por
el mínimo común múltiplo de todos los denominadores.
Aquí tenemos "x" sobre 1, 8 sobre 1, "x"
sobre 3 y 1 sobre 6.
El mínimo común múltiplo de 1, 3 y 6 es 6,
¿y qué va a pasar al multiplicar todo por 6?
Lo que va a suceder es que se van a
eliminar las fracciones.
Así es que al multiplicar éstas que inicialmente
eran fracciones por 6, ¿qué nos resulta?
6 por "x" menos 6 por 8 = 48, estamos
distribuyendo el 6, esto es igual a...
y del lado derecho tenemos "x" sobre 3 por
6, vamos a escribirlo tal cual, esto es 6
por "x" sobre 3 más 6 por 1/6, ahora el lado
izquierdo no se altera, "6x" menos 48
lo cual es igual a 6 por "x" sobre 3, 6 sobre 3 es
igual a 2, esto nos va a dar 2 que multiplica a "x",
"2x" más 6 por 1/6, 6 sobre 6 se cancelan
y queda simplemente 1.
Así es que este primero paso nos sirvió
para cancelar las fracciones, ya tenemos una
ecuación con coeficientes enteros que podemos
resolver directamente.
Ahora, lo que queremos hacer es llevar las "x" a un solo lado, vamos a llevarlas del lado izquierdo.
Vamos a restar "2x" a ambos lados, me quiero
deshacer de este "2x", por eso estamos restando
"2x", restamos entonces "2x" del lado izquierdo
y "2x" del lado derecho,
¿y qué obtenemos?
Del lado derecho tenemos "2x" más 1 menos
"2x" se cancelan las "2x" y nos queda tan solo el 1.
Del lado izquierdo tenemos "6x" menos "2x"
es "4x", cuando tenemos 6 de algo menos 2
de ese algo nos da 4 de ese algo, "4x" menos 48.
Ahora, necesitamos deshacernos de este -48,
para esto sumamos 48 a ambos lados de la ecuación.
Sumamos 48...
vamos a ponerlo con otro color...
sumamos 48 del lado izquierdo y 48 del lado derecho.
Con lo cual ahora tenemos "4x" menos 48 más
48 que se cancelan y nos queda tan solo "4x"
y del lado derecho nos queda 1 más 48 = 49.
Ya llevamos las "x" del lado izquierdo y ahora
para despejar "x" multiplicamos por 1/4
ó lo que es lo mismo, dividimos entre 4, dividimos entre 4 el lado izquierdo y dividimos entre 4 el lado derecho.
Del lado izquierdo "4x" entre 4, 4 entre 4
es igual a 1, nos queda tan solo "x",
lo cual es igual a 49/4.
Es lo más que podemos simplificar, pues 49
y 4 no tienen factores en común.
Comprobemos si 49/4 es realmente la solución,
sustituyendo ese valor en la ecuación original.
Recuerda, la ecuación original la tenemos aquí en verde, antes de que la multiplicáramos por 6.
En teoría podríamos sustituir el valor en
cualquiera de las ecuaciones
pero vamos a hacerlo en la ecuación original.
Así tenemos, "x" menos 8 es decir, 49 sobre
4 menos 8, que es igual a 49/4 sobre 3 más 1/6.
Bien, ¿y ahora qué hacemos?
Podemos hacer lo mismo que hicimos para resolver
la ecuación, es decir, multiplicar por 6
para deshacernos de las fracciones.
Vamos a hacer eso, vamos a multiplicar por
6 toda la ecuación y vamos a eliminar las fracciones,
entonces multiplicamos por 6 el lado izquierdo y multiplicamos por 6 el lado derecho.
¿Y qué obtenemos?
6 por 49/4, 6/4 se simplifica como 3/2,
así es que esto es igual a 3 por 49/2 menos...
menos 6 por 8 = 48, lo cual es igual a 6 dividido
entre 3 es 2 multiplicado por 49/4 nos da
49/2, 49 sobre 2 más 6 por 1/6 = 1.
Y aquí entonces lo que podemos hacer, creo
que lo voy a calcular directamente,
había pensado restar 49/2 a ambos lados de la ecuación y así simplificar los cálculos pero no,
lo voy a evaluar directamente para verificar
la identidad, hagamos entonces 49 por 3,
aquí podrías pensar que es 3 menos que 3 por 50 que es 147, pero vamos a hacer la multiplicación directamente.
3 por 9 = 27 llevamos 2, 3 por 4 = 12 y 2 = 14, 147,
así es que esto es 147/2 menos 48 y 48 lo voy a escribir en términos de medios,
48 es igual a 96/2, 96 sobre 2 es
48, así es que esto sería -96/2,
esto es igual a 49/2 más 1, que lo voy a
escribir como 2/2.
Ahora, ¿cuánto es 147 menos 96?
Si fuera 147 menos 100 tendríamos 47 y si
restamos 4 más obtenemos 43...
no, no, no... tenemos que sumarle 4,
pues nos estamos quedando cortos
entonces sería, 147 menos 100 = 47 más 4 = 51, 51/2 y esto es igual a 49/2 más 2/2, 51/2.
Así es que la solución obtenida es la correcta.